okay we are here talking about language
completeness and consistency and we have
a variety of items here um okay first up
datasets store now but okay so by
default a big data set
will not have all its data stored
directly in the notebook correct correct
what else like is there an icon eyes
that doesn't have everything stored in
the notebook or not yet no recognizes
you know its whole purpose is to dump
things into the notebook as it's
currently implemented I mean the other
things which have store now buttons are
things like sparse array and quantity
array and probably interpolating
function and some statistics functions
right so the store note button is really
for things which you know the kernel
computes a result but it's you know
large so we don't necessarily want to
stick all of it into the notebook right
and so you can see here with the whiter
data sets then the store Now button
looks just like it does for you know
sparse array or whatever other mm-hmm
you know thing does now for very narrow
data sets which is the top two images
then Billy has spec this little icon
which I guess is just the eye candy part
of of the store now button with a
tooltip right so I mean the fact that
it's red is because we think it's kind
of a warning that the data is not um you
know right there in the notebook right
exactly now I
have a big problem with this anybody
else have a problem with this mm well so
Mike my concern is about the narrow is
about the small button if it really
adequately and maybe it's just maybe
it's just me but I think people have to
get used to it and I think there's
nothing we can do in that term um is it
possible to click the button in the tool
tip and what tool tip in the tool tip
how do you know that there's a tool tip
there if you don't see anything yeah I'm
sure I understood that question bring
the store now is in the tool tip here
right and but I'm asking is it possible
to actually click a link that's in the
tool tip oh I asking is it technically
possible I don't think so yeah anyway
well we could have a pop-up yeah there's
have to be something else but right I
think the confusion is the Chevron at
the end store now usually that's a text
link so if maybe you didn't have the
Chevron it was just a period so that way
that actually what I implement it has a
slightly different wording it has the
same right it says something like click
data not a notebook click to store now
without the Chevron but that one doesn't
this one down here is just store now
right right because you click that
directly but this is in the tooltip but
you don't click so that's all hover
right and then that says click to store
and it tells you that you need to click
that in order to store it seems okay to
me what what's this blue color that you
love here yeah the hover effect this
looks fine really I think
sir is that if it says click you know
people may still try clicking into the
text instead of the original button yeah
maybe we should say click button to
store oh gosh come on
I mean wait see I mean it they won't
actually be able to click the text if
they move outward the text it'll
disappear yeah I guess that's true so
yeah I guess that's fine a little bit um
okay all right
good let's move on allows files a grid
style spec right so there there's an
example there at the bottom where if
this were implemented that list 1 1 and
list 3 3 could be written as spans so I
I am NOT a fan of this proposal
I don't spent span takes two arguments
doesn't it right so the what the list 1
1 could be span one span of 1 comma 1 or
you know 1 semicolon semicolon 1 if you
wrote it that way it could also be 1
semicolon semicolon 7 or something right
which that's one of my concerns that
span you know this is exactly what one
wants I mean so in other words if I said
1 7 here you misread that would seem
useful to me
yeah right but you could also just write
list 1 7 no but I know but the point is
that we didn't have span at the time
when we could find this quite obscure um
great specification language right which
is what one of my concerns right so
first of all I mean there's no such
thing as right the three elements ban
right there's no there's no such
equivalent in the grid language and
isn't that I mean isn't there I mean
couldn't you have alternating X Blanco
back read we don't have that I mean
though
have I mean you could I mean you can do
that as a you know as a sort of right
you can have the alternating specs you
know if you just give a spec but in the
rule language and no there isn't
look this is horrifyingly complicated
exactly arguably the whole thing should
be turned into something which has a
more symbolic specification I mean so so
basically my argument is its horrifying
ly complicated you know I and you know
really this list one one thing is only
really documented via an example there
isn't even really a note that speaks to
that so there isn't know it so it says
you know Sparrow no expect one it rules
but nowhere does it say that rules can
be what to use at this position it
doesn't say there's a multi dimensional
right is that multi dimensional that is
what do we even know oh it's because if
you change that one one two one three
can we see what happens there maybe get
rid of the 3/3 rule right so that'll be
so you're just
by undocumented rights okay so did I
actually typed this in wrong because
there is certainly a way to get columns
1 3 so yeah if you scroll down to the to
the scope examples there is an example
which shows that it can be a span like
thing and
[Music]
you
yeah Samuel and I live streams pointing
out alternation as possible yeah that's
that's right alternation is possible and
this okay the fact that this thing I'm
totally confused by what this even is I
mean right and there and I think I think
about that extra brace doesn't help
anything right so I think right so what
is the way to do like I said can you
scroll down to the to the scope examples
on yeah I mean I think this is the
documentation is not right here and
scroll down a bit more there will be
[Music]
okay so that's that's okay so I I guess
that is the example I took which I
thought was the one that showed Chris
okay well this one here it's just
totally weird position one one in
position three three in the grid I know
that but but this example those first
two things are okay hold on let me read
something here
oh look look look look look yeah the
third element is the special thing right
it's though it doesn't then document but
it needs to document that up here needs
to document what rules can be right I
mean honestly what we should do here is
we should provide an alternative syntax
that is an association that says Rosero
blah columns arrow blah
you know how arrow blow so all right so
I know what I did wrong
okay so yeah so if you if you scroll
down one more example to in the the
right so that one where you where the
left hand side is completely
undocumented right that behavior is
completely undocumented right and so
that what that one three is what can be
replaced
magnified span affine okay so what what
else Spanish eyes like that I mean in
other words if I did that as a sparse
array does sparse array allows spanning
like that
um sparser a has been did I'm not sure
if it'll as well it won't to love that
oh yeah it could allow that right it
dispensed sparse retakes right rules
right you know pattern rules right so
you could have like you know oh and I
think that's this seems like a useful
thing because I mean it does take banded
right and whereas grid doesn't take
bandit
yes oh so this particular thing that
thing there
make sense as intervals
in the case look okay we've got a mess
on our hands here yes I agree we've got
I mean what should be the case is that a
sparse array specification I mean what
if you actually give a sparse array as
the grid background for example or
something like that I mean in other
words it should interoperate grid and
sparse array should interoperate I mean
sort of you don't really have a sparse
grid right I mean so no but but I'm
saying that that you can spray color
into the grid
right right right now look a span seems
like a very natural thing to use in a
good specification I I would agree if it
you know if we actually supported you
know skips which we don't in what and
spam in in grid
right so you don't support scripts but
we do because we have this with no no no
we don't only on the right hand side I
mean you can effectively make it skip by
giving it a list of okay but we couldn't
principle I think I think we just sort
of gave up the ghost before we got to
that I don't see why we shouldn't in
principle we can clearly have a rewrite
rule that goes from a a a skipping span
to something in the grid specification
so so how can Chris how can you do that
so you're saying if you change the
right-hand side to say list of pink
Scion then it it alternates and if you
set aside you use none it effectively
skips AC okay but listen let's zoom out
for a second we've got two different
things going on here one is the arrival
of table view right which is coming I
don't know where the table view
can I see table view here
um I mean the final arrival after a
decade of tableview so if I say table
height of the J I goes to ten J goes to
ten and then I say table view of that
okay now how does this relate
on earth is that and that hasn't been
designed yet by the way here we can
clearly drag out the size
for grid
I know what we would want it to do I
mean and I don't know the relationship
we've now got three constructs grid data
set and well tableview is purely
two-dimensional
as is gritted I mean right well even is
asking could we could he resize grids by
dragging like graphics I don't think
that makes any sense what you want to do
increase the gutter sizes because that's
the only thing that's flexible as the
gutter sizes the actual element sizes
well if you want to resize like graphics
use graphics grid that's its point
for an image size option to grid that's
that's not what you should do what you
should be doing is using graphics grid I
don't know what happens if I say
graphics grid of you know some set of
random numbers what does this do hum
just do something yeah I think that's
hunky-dory I mean that that does look at
that I bet we don't look at that
document it does not require graphics
input so it automatically graphics
suffice well it's you know insect can
eat anything you know if you had big
long things I have no idea what the line
wrapping behavior would be probably
complain that graphics good is old and
slow I don't believe that's the case if
it is I mean I don't think it's slow but
it's you know a v6 function so what I'm
just saying you know in response to the
old claim
now what happened here oh wow that's
cool I had no idea that worked but I
mean I think there are I mean I have
certain things I would like of sort of
improved item size specs and grid but
okay my question is this okay so first
of all how much of the of the grid okay
let me let me just try this right and
let me let me point out that the
greatest work almost maybe but I doubt
it
okay fine prove me wrong I am pretty
sure that graphics grid does not you
know have feature to feature parity with
grid well that should be looked at
yes that's why we're in a language
completeness and consistency with an
emphasis on completeness correct yes
right this is cool I did not know this
worked right okay so let's zoom out for
a second okay so we've got a couple of
issues one is the specification of sub
arrays in for styling for grid and
graphics grid and so on okay how that
relates to the specification of sub
arrays for things like sparse array
alright so for example banded is surely
not supported in grid no even though it
could perfectly well be in principle I
mean in other words right although let
me point out that the you know these
specs well they're not you know in brit
or not well they're not a hundred
percent they do largely correspond to
what the front end supports so for
example if you do two three like you did
there and you add rows then it will
continue to highlight two three but if
you did two minus three and you added
rows then you know and then it would you
know so let me add a row okay
cool
that's nice now notice of course that
with graphics grid I'm out of luck in
terms of adding a row right okay there
was a question from Brian why didn't the
font size increase when the graphics
grid is enlarged now I think I can say
can't I or could I stay there in terms
of the font size if I say styled here
can I use a scaled specification for
font size you should be able to you
might have to explicitly say font size
but you can try because you wrapped it
around the whole right you need a map at
level two or something okay so I have to
I have to style all right I'll just map
it at level two you can probably his
base style I'll just do the two the very
pedestrian thing of mapping a call to
here okay now let's see what happens
that
beautiful
right so that's magnificent I wonder
whether there's an example in the
documentation that shows that if there
isn't there should be I'm sure there
isn't yeah I was gonna say I'm
reasonably confident there isn't I think
we should have that so just took a
screenshot of it and arguably we should
have some workflow about making grids
that cuz this is useful I mean this is
this some um
Sandra's complaining that graphics could
uses insects oh I see sings so DEET
Santa thing yeah it's true isn't it that
he uses and sets currents I mean the
thing is is that if it's arbitrary it
because okay there's a complaint from
Ethan that graphics grid is too slow why
is it true I mean it-it's good quite a
bit and I have to say I don't find it
particularly slow I was gonna say the
ones you're doing right now haven't
seemed especially slow here's examples
you should make sure to send them in
yeah I've used it quite a bit and I
don't think it I don't see it as being
slow I mean I the only thing that I can
imagine that goes wrong is the insanity
of well let's let's look at this did we
ever solve this problem oh by the way
you still owe me a graphics row
you know packing stuff Bret
yes which hopefully is coming right
improvements are coming a little bit in
12.1 and after whichever meeting we were
discussing this in last week I came up
with an idea for how it might be
possible to do the dynamic resizing
in a more efficient way than I had been
thinking which will will probably slow
down graphics screen a bit but oh okay I
think this is an issue here what did I
just do here table what on earth
okay so this is the hard case right
maybe not I mean that that ground away
for a while when it first round yeah it
took a second maybe two there I probably
wouldn't see the absolute timing will it
well two seconds okay what was it doing
it was trying to solve some optimization
problem right I mean this guessing it
was I mean was it rasterizing things I
mean it shouldn't need to restoration
that can own oh there's no rasterization
the issue is solving think about the
following problem this thing has a
certain width and height for each each
row right
I don't think it's doing any
optimization it's doing an actual
optimization problem I mean it's me it's
running a heuristic to know it was doing
at some point it was using constrained
men to do actual optimization you can
buy the Whaley for just the timing for a
list of those graphics
that's instantaneous there's no work
that happens there okay so I claim if I
do absolute aspect ratio 2:1 here for
example I think it's still gonna be two
seconds okay that's crazy what the heck
is it doing Brett that's for you to
figure out yeah I mean it's gotta be
doing we don't know go figure it out
yeah that's that's weird and crazy
um however I I kind of want to know you
know we don't have a way of displaying
these graphics in a sense Pinterest
style do we was it image collage no
that's not quite venture style because
Pinterest style has what columns that
are backs fixed-width unfixed height
right so it's packed for column
basically I don't vent
we need that option because we have a
gallery do you we call Pinterest back
there but we have that option in gallery
view okay so if we can if we can note
that down talk about that but this is
outrageous this to second thing is
outrageous um
okay so someone is asking if we can just
do this alright let's see we have the
technology here we can I don't know
whether we I mean if if that
okay what on earth is going on here look
at that thing look at that oh I'm pretty
sure it's a restoration type thing to
measure so let's find out let's find out
is it going up as a square or not
doesn't look like a square to me that
looks super quadratic right if I'm oh
maybe it'll run I'm wrong I'm wrong I'm
wrong I'm wrong it's exactly it's
quadratic okay right so so we're hitting
some cost per graphic gotta figure out
what's going on um
it's for
it's okay um all right how much collage
multi-column are both Ethan is pointing
out multi-column does the Pinterest
style thing but a gallery really think
so missing feature Ethan would love to
see is a proper 2d tree map
which is an intrinsically dynamic
visualization isn't it or am i confused
it can be static I mean but in I mean
usually it's gonna have a tooltip or
something is you're gonna get rectangles
that are really small I see and okay so
so by the way Brett we are supposed to
have our graphics visualization types
summit meeting sometime soon okay
and how widespread should that be
whatever you I mean whatever you've
considered I mean all the random things
that people have asked for and so on
let's look at them all let's try and
prioritize them okay
we'll pull together the right and go now
that should certainly be in there tree
may observe no yeah I mean the
difficulty with the tree map is that
and drawing the tree map is relatively
easy the big question is you know sort
of what form the data is coming in as
it's just really weird things and so
yeah I know it's at allé on livestream
I'm certain it's the graphics grid
that's slowing it down although I should
check um I mean I'm sure if we do this
just with the graphics without graphics
grid it should be instantaneous 10 to
the minus sixth or whatever yeah it's
instantaneous something's going wrong
with graphics good Zoe Thanks I think
it's working harder to get a size of
something than it needs to in this case
either that or it's doing something okay
we gotta find this this is a problem
I don't think Ethan needs to send an
example I already have the example yep
it's horrifying we should fix it okay um
really horrifying I'm really surprised
this didn't come up before um but
there's a lot of corners
let's see um hold on there's a few other
comments that are interesting um whether
through dataset tableview whatever i
really like to have an easy adjustment
of things like truncation threshold and
wrapping for raw data visualization so
that's coming with dataset right - Chris
yes yes that's gonna be in 12:1 Karl is
asking nice way to working better with
cloud published with interactive arrows
dataset with cloud publish I believe
that is being dramatically improved as
well right Chris have you been involved
in that or not
no okay cloud publish and dataset I have
not looked at that you should I mean I
think it's working progressively better
and I think in 1.53 which should should
be pushed this week to production I
think it will work even better
okay I'm so impressed with that you know
I've I was just over the weekend I was
producing these giant notebooks and I
press cloud publish and it just works
it's amazing I'm amazed at least um it's
just a lot of stuff has to work to make
that happen
yeah Bennis is also complaining about
dataset and cloud published so we do
need to track that down but I have been
tracking that and I believe it has been
improving if not
yeah let's track it down and and Chris
you should take responsibility for
making sure that all the stuff you're
implementing on the desktop actually
works in the cloud yeah absolutely
okay all right um
so before we declare this done it was
not declaring it done we know we haven't
done so basically my argument is you
know we should figure out what we
actually want
I didn't style specs to look like
instead of making this one point change
oh I completely agree
I completely agree and I'm I'm saying
that we have this whole family of
essentially cookie cutters that is
things that take an array and describe a
sub array described repeating elements
in an array and so on and whatever they
are they better also work you know if I
want to
wouldn't it be annoying if I could give
a beautiful specification of how to
color red and green in a grid but I
couldn't actually get an actual sparse
array that had though or an actual array
that had those reds and greens in them
mm-hmm all right so what we need is some
converter that goes from one of these
specifications whatever wacky thing it
is and takes that specification and you
know even this specification here the
fact that we have no function that will
take a specification like that and
generate an array that is filled
according to that specification is
annoying you know it's like an array
fill or something or array I don't know
what it is exactly and I don't know how
it relates to structure to raise or to
the specifications for sparse array but
that's what I think we should study okay
this is pretty central to all of the
data set options so whatever happens
there is gonna have an impact on my work
all right wait which data set options
all the formatting options background
alignment all that stuff and are you
modeling that on on grid or what yes
yeah but okay because let's have a
dedicated meaning with some of the
relevant people which are you saying
it's gonna be extended to be
multi-dimensional Chris yes exactly I
mean I have extended it I have a
proposal but you know this is gonna be
affected by whatever all right well I
recommend that we think about a wrapper
of some kind that describes or or a
thing here anyway whatever it is
got to be a function that will just give
you an array filled in this way well
you're basically saying here's this
thing like sparse array here's the
specification here's the size of the of
the cookie whatever I'm I'm a analogy
with cookie cutters is failing here but
you know here's the size of the tray so
to speak
now go fill it according to the
specification
yet um okay let's come back for a second
to table view is anybody here working on
this this is not the right group to
discuss table view is it no we would
need John or I'm not sure who took it
over after Aaron left so all right but
this is there's a lot of elaborate stuff
in table view which we're not seeing
here yet with all kinds of options of
what happens and so on so and I don't
even know what happens if you if you
evaluate table for you you get another
table view okay I wonder what happens if
I say normal of that oops
well table view I believe is you know
like listpicker
or oh that's nice right so it should it
should be a control just like you know
let's pick her or you know tree you know
tree view or whatever it's called and
maybe write all of our different
controls well the thing that's not
happening here which I'm suppose it is
happening that's magnificent look at
that magnificent thing
and as this even more magnificent oh
look at that
can you do that and yes you can and
there what about the vertical height oh
my gosh Wow all modern conveniences okay
well I it will be good if we can find
out when we're actually reviewing table
view this looks very promising what
happens if I try typing in text here
you
actually what happens if I press shift
enter let's say
what is that is that a string
[Music]
totally confused by what this did I
think it's confused because you oh I
think you evaluated table view of
percent or no that well that's a
separate cell sorry I mean yeah I
evaluated this and actually what it did
here which wasn't bad was it treated
that by default as a string which is
actually good behavior mm-hmm um I'm
really looking forward to table view I
think it's one been a missing feature
forever and ever and ever I also want to
check and is that Devin who's here um
yes uh they we should check what store
it what the story of this and the cloud
is okay sounds good um
um Ethan is recommending we look at
spreadsheets in quick qu IP which I've
never heard of so um
Carla's saying tableview makes him want
excel in modern language well there
might be other things coming that are
different from that but um um okay
I'm just looking at
[Music]
um Holly is asking if the discussion
about the redline issues
I um I don't know when we're having our
next one of those it's a good question
when is the next public discussion of
user reported bugs and redmine we should
probably try to do that this week before
the technology conference next week um
so if you could point that out although
I'm traveling a bit this week so they
end up being from some weird place um
okay so good Devin please find out what
kripp is go figure that out yes um go
figure out about the red mind discussion
and Ali is asking when it's two up on
one coming out we wish we knew but it is
getting closer getting warmer tumble the
quote Robert X crinkly real soon now or
computer industry expression meaning in
this lifetime maybe right um okay
all right so that's enough on this but
that's clearly this is clearly a design
mess what's happened here so let's clean
it up I mean this is it yeah I'll start
off with us we clearly need a separate
meeting with various stakeholders and go
from there okay fine full definition
should full definition stop a system
symbol as it stops
right so there and beyond apparently
there has been some discussion of full
definition and some group of people that
I haven't been a part of and so yon is
here to help us bring us this isn't full
definition used internally for all kinds
of purposes or how does it work in in
the case of cloud deploy when it is
pulling in it uses full definition is a
slightly lower level a kinda you know
language extended full definition but
it's essentially the same principle and
it's used so it's used if you deploy
something to the cloud that falls in
definitions but it's also used for
manipulates if you just use safe
definition nor even if they stay on the
diet up and also for prayer local
kernels I think to propagate definitions
from one kernel to another yeah I I know
it's quite widely used and I agree that
it's probably a very blunt instrument or
works surprisingly well considering how
blunt it is right and what we've run
into now especially with the cloud is
that if the different definitions blow
up it's much more of an issue in the
cloud then it was elsewhere probably but
that's why we only now find these
various cases where it pulls in you know
red so yeah visuals and definition so
let me let me comment on a related thing
I abjure the fact that the autocomplete
sometimes shows me weird symbols in
weird subterranean contexts have people
noticed that
nobody else it said on you know if
you've added something to context past
then it will show you absolutely but it
also is showing me like I'm sure I can
do that right now if I go here and I I
say look at that okay why is it showing
me stuff from the Pacolet manager well
cuz you're gonna tell me that's all my
comics s okay all right does anybody
know by the way why the document
generator fails to when I evaluate a
template notebook with the Pacolet with
something from this why does it it is
bizarrely sandboxed itself does anybody
know why that happens
because that's again a full definitions
like thing right I mean because when you
build okay so this is a case where full
definitions is probably not being
correctly used right so you build a
template notebook right you generate you
use generate
document okay I was able to use this for
a very beautiful purpose over the
weekend
um but the question is does that
generate document to gender stamina
masking it it is not
it is not pulling in the definitions it
needs for the for the template notebook
does that make sense
everybody's silent yeah I don't use it
often enough to really appreciate what
you're saying okay let me show you what
I'm saying this is have an option on
whether to pull things in or not because
that's not it appears not to which seems
to me to be an oversight because here if
and I think Anthony in the UK is the one
that Tim um see so if I have a template
notebook here and I put in an expression
and that expression says let's say
Pacolet install
of foo okay all right
so that see that's blue that which is a
little odd
right right which means they have been
disabled
oh but coz it should be black because
it's some context path this is what
you're saying right now pack of hands is
it on context path for that notebook or
maybe they maybe they ha I uh yeah I so
it's got its own separate context path
similar to the darks and whatnot
well ok so what this needs is an option
a save definitions option because it's
got to have those things otherwise when
this generates it's just going to do the
wrong thing
you
right right well I will explain Devon if
you could screen capture this and send
this to Sushma who is probably trying to
chase this particular issue for me
yes forget it yeah um okay
by the way Ethan is mentioning gallery
view and saying with an in notebook
version of galleries you'll be useful I
thought we had that now do we not have
that now
what the heck is this crazy example come
on guys can somebody please fix that and
not have a stupid example like that do I
have to write the example here come on
come on just put okay nobody here except
possibly on has any connection together
review so ok well so I don't know track
it down please don't use this example
it's a really dumb example please use an
example that has an actual
it's really really dumb example and
isn't like eight inputs for the first
basic example yes yes totally dumb
totally irrelevant and totally dumb and
this delayed thing is fine
no no okay Devon if you can't get this
fixed I will rewrite this it will take
like three minutes okay let me know if
you okay yell oh sure okay so let's say
oh my gosh why doesn't it work in the
notebook it needs to I mean that's
probably for somebody like Lou to deal
with should be really straightforward
crazy
that's really crazy that doesn't work
thank you for pointing that out
Ethan sigh Devin please go chase that
one yep
okay all right back to full definition
okay first point is the the eye if I can
just one point if you look at the
example I put there right so when you do
full definition of f you see a
definition related to dollar assumptions
because other assumptions isn't
protected and obviously you can't
protect other assumptions because it's
you know a user set a poll variable but
there's no there's nothing showing for
plot because plot is protected that's
sort of the current behavior the
question is should we exclude all system
symbols or maybe have an excluded
context goes to you know various values
to have a finer greenery control I think
we need to find a control that's for
sure and let me understand so also for
the stack for stack viewing right on a
message break doesn't that prune context
as well
prune contexts as well it does and how
does it prune and is it consistent in
its pruning okay okay but it also prunes
inside oh I see so as it goes into a
system symbol it prunes any internal
stuff right so basically for every frame
in the stack it basically essentially
does a free Q of symbol not on context
path and if that's true it keeps it and
if it's false it prunes it okay all
right so what are you proposing here I
mean I'm worried that excluded context
is not going to be enough that you have
to have more stuff about protection etc
etc right so the I mean I think for for
Yuans purposes and being able to exclude
you know system and maybe a couple of
other contexts would be you know solve a
lot of their problems of course then
there's the possibility of like if you
have to code if you're you know if
you're manipulate changes dollar
assumptions then that might get lost
somehow between the kernel and the cloud
and that would be a problem also but
maybe a less bad problem than whatever
Yann is experiencing right now so but I
think I think at least as a first step
forward having an excluded context that
allows you to specify which things to
exclude would be a useful for the first
step so in it save definitions right now
just has true or false
automatic but okay but then excluded
context is effectively a sub option to
save definitions in some sense
sewer I mean to my mind save definitions
could explode into a big association of
details
because I think there's more work that
has to be done on this I think this is
not I mean this is a very undefined
thing you know what does it mean to take
the state of the system and transport it
somewhere I I mean we will be much
better off if everything was immutable
and we had no state but realistically I
mean like do you take the state of the
random number generator do you take what
states what do you take do you take you
know we don't take user metadata like
the geolocation and we don't take the
round number to see do we we don't I'm
sure we don't take that no okay but so
arguably we need a definition of what to
take right and and right now I mean full
right full definition has one which is
all symbols that appear progressively
until you run into protected symbols and
then stop when you hit a protected
symbol which for system symbols which
are not protected either because they
don't want to be protected or because of
implementation details you know that is
sort of apparently hitting the cloud in
various ways yeah it's bad okay listen
guys my prediction is that this needs to
get significantly more sophisticated and
that it's going to end up with a bunch
of fairly elaborate rules which I don't
see why you shouldn't parameterize
particularly as we experiment with them
and so on mm-hmm go ahead I mean I think
excluding system symbols would probably
go a long way and I think maybe if
something like all the assumptions
doesn't propagate into the cloud that
might be just fine okay
I might not yeah look what I mean maybe
maybe not but I think I think we're
gonna need these to the context we're
gonna need included symbols excluded
symbols etc etc etc right I mean I think
we're going to I would recommend an
association that has many many different
pieces included symbols that stupid
symbols included context exclude
contexts those are the two obvious
things and then maybe it's not to make
sure pretend but but we still need a
reasonable default right that should not
usually explode that I agree I agree
completely but I mean that may be a big
list of included symbols that
you know we have to tag in some way now
the other possibility are we able to
assign more attributes or attributes
kind of tapped out
anybody know there there may be a bit
for one more attribute because we freed
up something we did some expert cleanup
a couple of years ago but I would have
to check with mark or Rob to know for
sure about and even though it's 64-bit
we still have that that field is not
expanded right because it would
basically change the alignment of the
whole exper if we did that and which
isn't that lovely how we go from these
how we have to go to these very low
level issues occasionally yeah all right
fair enough but but okay so I mean for
example I can imagine something where
some configuration of attribute bits is
determining whether to like protected as
one unlocked will be another read
protected and other and so on would
define whether it like read protected
presumably you never want to you know
save those presumably presumably yeah
and that's that's the logic right now if
it's really fits protected or read
protected it's not included okay but
it's not obvious that protected
shouldn't be included
just means they're not writable it
doesn't mean it's not readable mm-hmm
look I think the logic needs to get more
complicated I think we really have got
to just try and analyze corners of what
it means to have you know have the state
um okay but I think what I would
recommend doing immediately is
introducing an association to represent
what
you know call it something like um well
I mean save definitions is a um
something more like included definitions
or something included definition rules
something like that and that actually
that exists like I think there was that
switch already for at least cloud
functions there's an option called
include definition no it's not no call
safe definitions anymore for those okay
fine
so then include definitions I recommend
turning that into a great big
association at least you know what we
can do for right now is have a named
option you know a string named option
for include definitions that references
some defaults big I mean the automatic
reference some bigger default
Association but at least we should
parameterize it allowing an association
so that we can experiment with what goes
on and then gradually start adding and
subtracting symbols from that that's
what I recommend seem reasonable
mm-hmm yep
Brian our livestream suggested
essentially the same as what I just
suggested good that's I'm also
encouraged that okay okay you know think
that the question officer is who will do
that experiment this event who will do
all the testing to that's going to be
somewhere in the Atty orbit yeah but no
I mean we'll need a little kickoff
meeting with with you and when and
whoever else you think should be there
just who's the you hear me
gone yeah yeah I was gonna say that each
I you know if it's a miserable you can
still you know pull yarn into it and
yeah that's what I think should happen
okay under when do you get in town yawn
next week okay or Sunday he's suggesting
why not live stream the entire
technology conference I think aren't we
life's too mean pieces of it I don't
know what exactly what the what the plan
is there you know there's live streamed
and everything else is recorded and then
uploaded to you know why would not live
streaming it we might as well live
stream it um the so somebody should
suggest that to Danielle and let's see
what I can fit my I was gonna say
whoever does that should do it from you
know more than arm's length away why is
it totally aren't we recording well
aren't we I mean we just have to well I
don't know what's involved
let me not let me not say anything about
this but but um when was it lost last
year oh it was like three hours and 45
minutes for the keynote or something yes
this year I have a lot of material
that's not a good sign I think it'll
have an intermission okay
so ignore those those those captions
there because somehow something bad
happened to them so there was the
suggestion about create intermediate
directories and we looked at
things that take an override target
function I think I think we need to do
this next time unless this is super
urgent for this time let's let's well
yeah I don't know if we got something
from system modeler if there's somebody
from system modeler here I'd like there
so so basically these thing these three
functions take an override target option
but it's not clear to us what exactly
it's overriding if and if that has
anything to do with a create
intermediate directories option right so
basically we've been looking at the
documentation and we agree that it might
not be most regular use of a write
target because basically what we are
doing is resetting the value of psalms
badly or some symbols in memory so we
are not writing files okay yeah so yeah
so this one let's kick out kick this off
next time then right that sounds like
something completely different and
rather horrifying um okay just to
comment on the live stream there should
be a function to drop positions returned
from sequence position not sure I
understand that one um Brian this is
very making various comments about how
the attributes bits could be extended
yes yes we know the UM right I mean of
course they can be extended that creates
you know obviously MX file
incompatibilities and you know we need
its balancing you know various
constraints which you know we may
finally get to that point but for now it
you know we haven't seen an urge large
enough to you know sorry I lost
concentration what would you just say
what write that obviously we could you
know change changed the expert structure
and
add more bids but that would create MX
file incompatibilities and possibly
other issues I'm not thinking of no
that's not there I mean we know X Files
a version that would not be disastrous
but but there are many other issues
right um coming back to UM just comment
from Karl
any chance of a nice big dispersion
model being added dispersion of what in
what I don't know in what um another
question from Nikola here a create link
function for doing symbolic links yeah
why don't we have that we have so many
other file operations but we don't have
created symbolic link I think it's just
something we haven't gone around to
there was a proposal for that and I'm
not sure what its current status is I
mean
should not be difficult it's a very
straightforward system call on UNIX so
the question is right until when some
version of Windows 10 you had to have
admin privileges to create symbolic
links on Windows and so I'm not sure you
know we'd have to think about exactly if
we have a dedicated symbolic link we'd
have to think about exactly how it maps
on to two different systems that's
that's the only wrinkle and it's not
insurmountable it's yeah well maybe it's
become easier in Windows 10 in which
case that would be something to be
looking at now Ram would this only be
for symbolic links or also I don't know
regular links I would think but with the
symbolic link option um yeah I mean that
that seems useful and I I'm surprised we
haven't had more requests for it so can
we
um let's look at that one okay yeah
we're being being um the dispersion in
question is gasses in air okay well so
let me make a comment on that you say
wrapping thousands of lines of Fortran
code um in principle with library okay
so the issue is could you write a
function repository function that wraps
that Fortran code and the answer is not
yet but because of sandboxing of the
library code that in other words you
couldn't well
I believe for desktop distribution okay
here's a question for people come on
right one could certainly write
something come on right external
language code and included in the
function repository I think the answer
is the problem is that in like Python
for example there's all kinds of horrors
about you know which packages have you
loaded at which version are you running
etc etc etc in C code I think they're
issues about you know which executable
what machine you're running on and so on
but we have solved those problems we
solved them 25 years ago for with this
directory sandwich business and I think
as soon as you can put PAC --let's
and call them from a functional posit or
e that should work so my theory would be
take your Fortran code and wrap it in
the stuff that's needed to put it in the
function repository and then you'll be
able to do dispersion calculations in
Wolfram language forever just by calling
that function in the function repository
but there are some issues there right
now for example we can't some sandboxing
in the cloud of external code there's a
problem that we are currently in the
process of solving but that is not
solved yet um
brian is commenting on our livestream
that windows there's many options for
symbolic links junctions huddling soft
links etcetera okay well what is the use
case you don't convert the making of
links yeah what would they want the
Mountie directory or do you want just
creating a structure on your link to a
file trajectory I would assume it's just
making links between files I mean it's
just like why does anybody make a
symbolic link right well it's right well
you right it depends on the type when
may mean I'm not sure if this is the
point that Constantine is trying to make
but depending on the kind of you know
target different kinds of links are
possible right you can't have a hard
link to a directory listen I gotta go to
a different meeting but let's let's put
this on the agenda maybe for ILB another
time and those those who are following
the live stream we will actually be back
in another live stream about geometry
and graphics in about 30 to 45 minutes
um all right gotta go talk to you all
soon
okay bye